مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في نيوزلندا من قناه
الجزيره قتل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الشابين فلسطينيين احدهما من قاده كتيبه
جنين وجرحت اخرين خلال حمله اعتقالات
نفذتها فجر اليوم في مخيم جنين من الضفه
الغربيه وافاده مصادر الفلسطينيه الى قوه
اسرائيليه خاصه تسللت الى المخيم لتنفيذ
الاعتقالات
افادت مراسله الجزيره بالافراج عن الاسير
الفلسطيني ماهر يونس بعد انتهاء مده
محكومته بالسجن 40 عاما وكان ماهر وهو من
سكان داخل الخط الاخضر اعتقل بتهمه
المشاركه في قتل جندي اسرائيلي
اصدرت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه قرارا
يقضي بمنع الزعيم حركه شاس ارى درعي من
تولي اي حقيبه الوزريه في الحكومه والتي
يشغل فيها حاليا حقيبتي الداخليه والصحه
وانتقدت حركه شاس القرار ووصفتهم السياسيه
غير المعقول بينما استبعد زعيم المعارضه
قال البيت الابيض
ان الهدف من زياره السلف عند الاسرائيل هو
توضيح ما تتوقعه مباشره من نتنياهو
والحكومه الجديده بشكل لابسه فيه
نقلت وكالته اصل شركه بريستعمل مسؤولين
امريكيين تضع اللمسات الاخيره على حزمه
ضخمه من المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا
تقدر بنحو مليارين و 600 مليون دولار
نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤول في
البنت من قوله
بحاجه لي اسلحه تمكنها من استهداف شبه
جزيره القرم وان واشطا لم تقول ان القربه
يجب ان تكون خارجه نطاق الضربات
الاوكرانيه
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه الابرايس ان اداره الرئيس جوبا
ايدل ابلغت الكونجرس تاييدها بيع طائرات
اف 16 لتركيا وان الاتصالات جاريه مع
المشارعين الامريكيين في هذا الشات واضاف
برايس انه واشنطن تريد ان تضمن الحصول
انقره على ما تحتاج اليه كحاليفا في
النيتو
وكذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اهميه
التعاون بين بلاده وتركيا كحليين وعقبه
محادثات
مباشره قال بيانو مشتركين ناقشات تنفيذ
مذكره وقعتها في لندن السويد وتركيا هذه
المضيء قدما في طلب انضمامهما
وقال وزير الخارجيه الفن الهندي للجزيره
بلاده اوفت بكل تعهدات التي قدمتها لتركيا
في ما تعلق بالانضمام نيته وتوقع ان تساهم
زياره وزير الخارجيه التركيه الى الولايات
المتحده في حل اي اشكاليات عالقه بهذا
الملف
انتهى الموجز في امان الله
[موسيقى]